you
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for today's live webinar eliza like a
say for maps and the benefits of assay
automation i'm christy jewel of lab
routes and i'll be moderating this
session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrys the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Beckman
Coulter life sciences at Beckman culture
life sciences we are dedicated to
improving the health of people around
the world the company's global
leadership and world-class service and
support delivers sophisticated
instrument systems reagents and services
to life science researchers in academic
and commercial laboratories enabling new
discoveries in biology based research
and development for more information
please visit Beckman comm
now let's get started you can pose
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
drop down box located on the far left of
your screen labeled ask a question and
click send questions will be answered
after the presentation to enlarge the
slide window click on the arrows at the
top right hand corner of the
presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab sound at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing into that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credit
I would now like to introduce today's
speaker Philip and Gorman scientist in
antibody generation for biotherapeutics
discovery and Bohringer Ingelheim
Pharmaceuticals Philips earned a
master's degree in biology at Southern
Connecticut State University and
subsequently worked at the Yale School
of Medicine PerkinElmer thermo electron
and Pfizer
the majority of his expertise is in
immunoassay development and validation
he also has extensive experience in lab
automation and integration Philip now
oversees bell ringers high-throughput
antibody discovery team whose principal
duties are primary screening cloning and
transient expression of therapeutic
antibody candidates so the corpsman will
now begin his presentation
thank you and thank you for joining us
all today and I will be presenting
today's webinar analyze alike assay
formats and the benefits of assay
automation as a brief overview of what
we're going to be talking about today I
have a couple slides on my own personal
background and background of my employer
bearing or Ingelheim we'll go through a
recap of the standard eliza formats that
most scientists are familiar with and
then some as I refer to them eliza like
formats that are derived from this
overriding principle one that we will
focus on is electrochemical um in
essence and that is primarily put out by
a company called musa scale discovery
MSD so we'll go through an overview of
MSDS technology will touch on
implementing lab automation and varying
scope and scale I have an example of one
of our own platforms here at bearing err
which is an automated MSD screening
platform that we have named Skynet will
do an overview of different forms of
scheduling software and how they can be
used using Beckman Coulter's schedule or
Sammy as an example and we'll touch on
the needs and requirements of Si
validation in the realm of automated
platforms conclusions and then I'll be
glad to take any questions
burying her in haim is a family-owned
global corporation with multiple
subsidiaries throughout the world
obviously was founded in England Germany
given a name their current focus is
human pharmaceuticals animal health and
it is also one of the larger bio
therapeutic contract manufacturing
groups in the world bi has over 50,000
employees worldwide and in an R&D
expenditure of over 3 billion euro
currently the bio therapeutic Rd
headquarters is located in Ridgefield
Connecticut with research sites in
Austria Germany
and as I said multiple subsidiaries
throughout the world in animal health is
centered in Athens Georgia
self I received a bachelor's in
Physiology a neural biology from the
University of Connecticut in 1999 as I
received my master's degree in biology
from Southern Southern Connecticut State
University in 2007 I've been in the
pharma and biotech industry for a little
over 16 years and I've touched in
discovery research development sales
field applications
and should have worked for Yale
University PerkinElmer thermal electron
and Pfizer prior to my current position
here at BI the majority of that
experience is an immunoassay development
along with liquid handling automation
integration and assay transfer I have
been in employee of BI since 2011
is
as a format that most people learn
the acronym Eliza stands for
enzyme-linked immunosorbent assay and
these a things are very easy to develop
and run there are multiple formats
allowing for a significant amount of
flexibility in how they are set up there
are drawbacks to each of those formats
so we'll look at standard the four
formats that most people are aware of
that direct Eliza indirect Eliza
sandwich Eliza and the competition Eliza
and then I'll also bring up what I refer
to as a hybrid Eliza and then Eliza
alike or Eliza derived technologies the
first assay format that will touch on is
the direct Eliza direct line is much
faster than other Eliza techniques as
fewer steps are required the assay is
also less prone to error since fewer
reagents and steps are needed although
there are some disadvantages to this
method so in instance in which someone
might be using a direct Eliza is
looking at an activated cell type and
did my cells secrete protein X and how
much and direct Eliza only a single
conjugated antibody is used for antigen
detection so if you are trying to assay
a cell culture supernatant let's say for
eat your supernatant is coded on to the
plate but the coating is nonspecific
everything in that supernatant is coded
onto your plate you're going to probe
that plate with a conjugated anti io8
antibody so the only thing you're going
to detect is il-8
direct alliances are less flexible since
the specific conjugated primary antibody
is needed for each target protein that
you want to analyze and as there is no
secondary antibody use there is no
signal amplification this reduces assay
sensitivity the second essay format that
we'll look at is indirect Eliza the
indirect Eliza has a high sensitivity
since more than one labeled secondary
antibody can bind to the primary
antibody which results in a signal
amplification it is more economical than
a direct Eliza as fewer labeled
antibodies are needed you only need one
usually anti species IgG or IgM to
detect any of the primary antibodies
within your assay format indirect
alliance develop delivers greater
flexibility since different primary
antibodies can be used among the
disadvantages is possible crush
reactivity of secondary antibodies to
the adsorbed antigen which could
increase your background noise
also indirect alliances can take longer
to run than direct Eliza's since
additional incubation steps are needed
the indirect Eliza is usually most
suitable for determining total antibody
concentrations with a sample
sin which Alliance is another one that
most people are very familiar with a
sandwich Eliza requires the use of match
antibody pairs a capture in a detection
antibody
each an Ahmadi must be specific target
antigen but they cannot bind a similar
epitope there can be no overlap in the
binding epitopes so in this type of a
format one of the antibodies will be
coated down onto the plate your sample
will be come with an additional
incubation
your second matched antibody is applied
and then you're labeled secondary the
key advantage to a sandwich Eliza is a
high sensitivity and it can be two to
five times more sensitive than a direct
or indirect Eliza and it also delivers a
high degree of specificity since two
antibodies binding to the antigen are
required to detect it in an all high
amount of flexibility with setting up
your matched pairs of antibodies these
types of alliances are particularly
suited to the analysis of complex
samples since antigen does not need to
be purified prior to the assay yet still
delivers high sensitivity and high
specificity the final standard Eliza
format is the competition Eliza or
blocking Eliza this is the most complex
of the standard Eliza techniques however
each of the above sa types can be
adapted to a competitive format the
competitive or inhibition Eliza is
predominantly used to measure the
concentration of an antigen or an
antibody in a sample by detecting
interference in an expected signal
output essentially sample antigen or
antibody competes with a reference
material for binding to a limited amount
of labeled antibody or antigen
respectively the higher the sample
antigen concentration the weak or the
output signal indicating that the signal
output inversely correlates the amount
of antigen in the sample when antigen
would be used to cope multi-well plate
following standard blocking and washing
steps samples containing an unknown
antigen are then added label detection
antibody is then applying for detection
using relevant substrates such as
GMB or a BTS if there is a high
concentration of antigen and sample a
significant reduction in signal output
will be observed in contrast if there is
very little antigen in the sample there
will be a small reduction in the signal
output
versatility of these assay formats have
given rise to we'll say much more
complex and much more technology-based
assay formats that I refer to as allies
alike formats and you might be familiar
with some of them le spot is an enzyme
linked immunosorbent assay cell level
for this particular type of assay so
cells are cultured on a surface coated
with a specific capture antibody and the
presence or absence of stimuli proteins
such as cytokines or other growth
factors are then secreted by the cells
and be captured captured by that
specific antibody on the surface of the
le spot plate after appropriate
incubation time cells are removed and
the secrete molecule is detected using a
detection antibody in a similar
procedure to that of what you would see
in our Eliza the detection antibody can
be either by titillated and followed by
a streptavidin enzyme conjugated or the
antibody can be directly conjugated to
an enzyme by using a substrate with a
precipitating rather than a soluble
product the end result of this is
visible spots on the membrane surface
within the well each spot corresponds to
individual site occurrence cytokine
secreting cells and the le spot readers
rather than being a colorimetric
detector that you would normally see in
Eliza are actually camera based and can
identify and count the number of spots
per well
giving you a quantitative measure Samoa
is
developed by a company called quanta x
and stands for single molecule array
have developed an approach for detecting
thousands of single protein molecules
simultaneously using the same reagents
as a conventional Eliza this method has
been used to measure proteins in a
variety of different matrices including
serum plasma cerebrospinal fluid urine
cell extracts and several others at
symptom molar concentrations offering
roughly one thousand fold improvement in
sensitivity the approach makes use of
arrays of empty liter sized reaction
chambers which are termed single
molecule arrays given rise to the name
Samoa and they can isolate and detect
single enzyme molecules because the
array volumes are approximately two
billion times smaller than a
conventional Eliza well a rapid buildup
of fluorescent product is generated if a
label protein is present with diffusion
irrelevant at this size the high local
concentration of product can be observed
and only a single molecule is needed to
reach the detection limit
electrochemically min essence is a kind
of luminescence that is produced during
electrochemical reactions in solution
and this particular technology is
primarily the product of meso scale
discovery
I see set up in an ECL assay is very
similar to that of an Eliza where you
would code an antigen down on a 96 or
384 well plate and apply your sample the
difference what this method is instead
of a fluorescent or chroma genic
detection
the secondary antibody used in ECL
assays is conjugated to ruthenium and
the plates provided by MSD have
electrodes on the bottom
instead of adding a tmb or an e BTS
in order to read an MSDS a you would add
an a protic solvent and in this case
MSDS read buffer containing try propyl
amine so ruthenium in the presence of an
a protic solvent with the application of
a voltage produces light so the basic
setup is very similar to an Eliza but
the output signal is luminescent rather
than chroma genic or fluorescent so now
that we've gone over a few of the assay
formats of Eliza and those that derived
from those basic principles will touch
on automation and first of all what does
that mean automation to some people
means large systems that process
hundreds of plates in a day in a walk
away fashion to other people automation
can mean simply using a liquid handler
or a stacker me personally I think it
encompasses all of these things
automating a basic assay format is not
something that should be overlooked
it's not only complex assay formats that
can benefit from a degree of automation
now so what does this mean are we just
going to bring in a liquid handler or
dispenser automating and Eliza can be as
simple as
have assured in a reader with a plate
stacker it's allowing the scientist
to do non-routine tasks
routine work is being done by the
equipment in the lab so if you're going
to consider automating a basic assay
format you need to decide what you mean
by that
what do you hope to accomplish do you
want to increase throughput do you want
to standardize your sample handling do
you want to free up scientists to do
other things and you also need to
determine the scale and scope how big do
you want and what do you want it to do
benefits and some takeaways to
automating basic assay formats such as
Eliza with an Elijah there there is a
lower bar of entry you don't need to be
an automation expert in order to
successfully put analyzer earn Eliza
like a say format on to some kind of an
automation one of the greatest benefits
of automation is equal time treatment of
samples and we'll get into that a little
later when we talk about the scheduling
software I tend to refer to automation
assets within a lab as a force
multiplier
you're allowing one scientist to do the
work of two if they
can set up a platform and let it run
while doing other things it also
provides a degree of consistency in your
sample handling and your reagent
dispensing we all know how to pipette
and we should all know that we do not do
it exactly the same time every time
there is a degree of variance with that
if you use a liquid handler whether it's
something like a multi-drop dispenser or
multi-channel liquid handler setting up
the same protocol and running the same
method is going to be handled exactly
the same way every time
some of the liability is when it comes
to automating some of these types of
assays is automation generally is not
faster let's take a little longer to
complete the same tasks than it would
doing it manually
There is obviously a cost involved with
equipment purchase
getting buy-in for management there's
another stumbling block for some and
there's also you know the perceived lack
of expertise will this individual
expert
but offsprings can be overcome
as I said
some of the considerations you need you
need to look at when thinking about
automating any type of acetate work
within a lab is the time it takes
transfer is something that cannot be
overlooked either
development is usually done ah it is a
necessity to take your manual bench
method apply it to whatever automation
you are considering implementing and
making sure that you get the same
results training is something that gets
overlooked more than people might think
familiarity with the equipment and the
software that you're going to be working
with is extremely important when
considering an investment like this in
II provided to all individuals who will
be using this equipment maintenance
requirements are also something that a
lot of people overlook service contracts
have a cost
have significant benefit especially if
you
have critical equipment you know running
a screening lab we have several pieces
of equipment here that we would consider
critical and we have service contracts
on them that provide us 24 hour response
time because of those pieces of
equipment go down for any length of time
our workflow stops
some individuals prefer to not have
service contracts not anything some I've
had managers in the past that have
thought it would was a waste of money
but print tears mmm the vendors will
provide several tiers of service
contract and it's just a question of if
you decide you want one finding what
level of attention and cost suit your
needs
selection of the platform is obviously
very important and this is where the to
a particular brand or vendor is not
going to serve you well if their
instrumentation doesn't have the
capabilities that you need some people
know one type of instrument one type of
biller one type of plate reader and
that's the one they want to stick with
because they're familiar with it but
sometimes there are better options out
there for your specific needs that need
to be considered the cost of consumables
when running automated platforms or
automated systems you're generally going
to need an overage volume when it comes
to reagents you're going to be working
out of larger reservoirs
so that needs to be taken into
consideration for Eliza
says the most of the reagents are
generally not that expensive so a little
bit of overage isn't really that big of
a concern if you're running something
like alpha screen by PerkinElmer those
reagents are exceptionally expensive so
if you're going to be running that type
of an assay on an automated setting
reagent overage is a significant cost
consideration and by comparison
so MSD the reagents are relatively
inexpensive the place however are
considerably expensive given to the
unique nature and the embedded
electrodes so all of these things need
to be
take account when
proposing automating specific asset
types
in touching back on the SA transfer one
thing that really needs to be looked at
is that small changes in how you perform
your asset can have big effects in an
automated environment in resource
allocation and time to completion so at
this point I won't go over our process
here at bearing err briefly obviously I
cannot provide a lot of detail as to
what our discovery process is but I can
say that we do perform a large number of
tasks and it is a rather lengthy process
and we implement some degree of
automation at several points throughout
that process all of those steps in the
swim diagram here that you see that are
in red boxes are steps in which we have
some degree of automation and that can
we have Kawai platforms several
workstations or just a liquid handler to
help with bulk transfers
as an example I'm going to focus on the
implementation of an automated platform
for one of our primary screening
methodologies that takes place in the
beginning of our process and that is MSD
so the reason that we decided to create
an automation platform around the MSD
was several fold
have the potential of running a higher
volume of plates up to 120 plates per
screen in 384-well format the assay
method that we have developed here is
not overly complex it's actually
relatively simpler than other methods
but there is a high degree of quote
unquote hands-on time required which
leaves scientists that is running that
particular screen unable to address
other tasks but given the high number of
plates it was very difficult to ensure
equal time treatment between samples
most of the components that went into
the design of this platform we already
had on hand from a previous platform and
as I've said previously a walk away
automation platform such as this allows
scientists to focus on non routine
experiments a/c development for other
projects that sort of thing
and we've already talked about the
six of the msds a format and how their
technology works it does have a
significantly greater sensitivity than
your standard Eliza and can easily get
down to picogram per mil even have two
gram per mil levels
of some analytes of given the way the
detection apparatus works is a CCD
camera and it only registers a
luminescent signal
within a certain distance from the
bottom of the well so as a result any
unbound conjugate in the fluid column
that would normally contribute to
background and other assays does not in
this setup so you have a very very clean
background signal in an MSD setup we use
two specific asset types here one of
which is an indirect Eliza and the other
is a hybrid indirect Eliza that we've
developed in-house here
so our hybrid format is combining
sample our secondary detection antibody
and a bite in elated antigen letting
those reagents equilibrate overnight in
polypropylene plates to reduce any
binding to the plastic
the day that combined sample and
detection reagent are applied to blocked
the streptavidin coated plates a
one-hour incubation standard wash
protocol add the read buffer and read on
the MSD instrument ours is a sector s
600 we also use an indirect Eliza
standard type format when we have an
antigen that cannot tolerate being by 10
elated so we will coat that antigen down
on MSDS high bind plates which are
similar to any Eliza plate that you
would see like an emu LAN or a Max's orb
add sample incubate wash
at secondary detection which is also the
Racine iam labeled detection anime same
detection antibody incubate wash ad read
buffer and read on the MSD instrument so
we've developed automated methods on
this new platform for both of these
assay formats
the components of this Skynet platform
we have a biomech fxp dual arm hybrid so
it's a 384 multi-channel head and a span
a inside of a hepa enclosure like
Connick LP x 220 Hotel ambient hotel
biotech al 406 washer plate washer
multi-drop combi the MSD sector a 600
reader we have a Burt - extended range
plate handler and - 39 inch servo
shuttles
and this is the overall layout of our
platform and the only pieces of
equipment for this layout that we had to
purchase specifically for this are the
ones that are highlighted in red is the
Burt two in the rear
servo shuttle
so this was a bit of a budgetary
experiment from our side of things we
wanted to build a platform to automate
our MSD primary screening in a walk away
fashion while also making use of
components that were left over from a
previous screening platform that has
been discontinued
to make the most of the equipment that
we had as I said it was composed almost
entirely of existing components with
only two needing to be purchased new we
also utilized
a fabrication shop which does amongst
other things metalworking to create an
enclosure on the laconic hotel which is
featured in the in the foreground of the
picture here since MSD assays are
light-sensitive and incue bation is
going to be taking place inside this
hotel we needed
there was an excess door to go on the
hotel and our fabrication shop here on
site FBI was able to
this is for this for us at almost no
cost the total cost to implement this
particular platform was less than
$150,000 and if anyone has any
experience with implementing setups like
this you will know that that is almost
an absurdly low price tag for something
like this if all of the components were
purchased new with the engineering cost
this would easily be over half a million
dollars
so I have provided some some photos of
our current setup in the top left and
top right picture is taken from behind
the biomech FX so we have a servo
shuttle that's actually coming out of
the rear of the biomech and that's where
the remainder of the components are in
being serviced by the Burtt with the MSD
reader the multi-drop and the plate
washer
the like Hunnic hotel is connected to
the biomech by ii 39 degree servo
shuttle which you can see in the bottom
left picture and you can see the exit
out the back of the biomech on the
bottom right
it is not
we'll say the most elegant design but it
is definitely functional and really met
our desire to do this almost entirely
with pre-existing components we do have
as you can see an integrated integrated
barcode reader the upper-left photo and
in the bottom Center easy access into
the MSD
and just a side note the MSP reader and
any of the components on this system can
still be used in an offline fashion can
be used as individual instruments when
the system is not running so if someone
needs to just run an MSD plate they
don't have to feed it into this platform
they can just use the MSD reader as a
standalone
and Beckman Coulter was the integrator
for this project and what I mean by that
for those that are unfamiliar the
integrator is the vendor that will
provide the scheduling software and do
all of the engineering to make sure that
all the components are able to
seamlessly communicate with one another
and why we chose Beckman Coulter as an
integrator if you have any experience
with this type of equipment you know
there's there's a lot of choices out
there for integrators and some of the
best-known our companies like Hamilton T
can high res thermo and even PerkinElmer
the individuals that I work with here in
my lab we already have a large amount of
expertise with the biomech platforms in
particular in other Beckman products in
general there were budgetary
considerations around this particular
platform that led us to stay with
Beckman as the integrator for this
platform as they were the integrator for
the previous incarnation of this
platform we do have individuals in our
lab that have little to no experience
with liquid handlers so we do have a
wide range of expertise and personally I
have found that the biomech software is
the easiest to teach novice level users
of liquid handlers and also Sammy
Beckman's integrated scheduler software
is much easier to teach than some other
scheduling software's out there and
that's particularly my comfort level as
the one that was going to be doing the
majority of the training we do
a lengthy existing relationship with
Beckman Coulter
and we have close to a dozen Quint
handlers within our department so we do
have a very solid relationship with
Beckman as a company and lastly the
quality of the service organization is
something that we place we FBI place a
lot of
value on
we do have a long-standing relationship
with our individual service engineers
that are working on the majority of our
our platforms here and it is something
that we are very comfortable with and
all of these reasons together are why we
chose Beckman Coulter as the integrator
for this particular project here and as
I alluded to a few times Sami is the
scheduling software that Beckman Coulter
uses for their integrations so
scheduling software is probably best
described as an overlay for all of the
components within an integrated platform
it's a controller software it is the
console that you will use to build your
methods and control all of the
individual components within your
platform Sami has a very easy to
understand graphic user interface which
can show you visually how your protocol
is going to progress what lab where is
being drawn into what step where it's
coming from
how long each step is going to take
methods like this are built based on one
plate
build your assay format in this graphic
representation about how one plate would
progress through the scheduler software
will then take all of those processes
and interleave them with one another to
get maximum efficiency out of the
process as I said earlier Sammi I have
found to be one of the easiest
scheduling software's to teach new users
it also has an ability to stack
protocols into a run queue providing
that your system has enough storage
capacity and resource to handle both or
two or three protocols in a row if you
can put enough consumables and plates
and whatnot in there to handle
everything that you need it's very easy
function for stacking those protocols
into a run cute much easier than I found
with other platforms
back to some
I mentioned in one of the earlier slides
small changes leading to big impact when
I was doing the initial method
development for this MSD screening assay
I kept approach that I used at the bench
and I put it into Sami as I was doing it
manually
result was for a
standards 30 played screen would take
over 14 and a half hours which is
something that we it was not viable for
what we're doing the simple action of
swapping two steps in the protocol
just order of reagent addition which is
irrelevant to this assay setup raw 14
and a half hour timeframe down to five
and a half hours which was much more
viable for what we were doing and a lot
of that is around resource allocation
within an integrated system if you have
your liquid handler being used too much
to move components around your system
that resource is not available to do any
liquid handling
so that is going to greatly stretch out
the overall time that it's going to take
for something like this so as I said
just swapping two steps within the
protocol it didn't fundamentally change
the protocol at all I just added reagent
to first instead of second and that
brought the time down by over 70%
resource allocation within an integrated
system is the overall driver for the
length of your method
and another thing that I had touched on
and the preceding slides was equal time
treatment and what I mean by that is
treating your samples in the exact same
manner
for every single plate and that applies
to liquid handling mixing shaking
washing incubating in reading for
example our MSD reader the sector s 600
for the 384 well plates that we use in
our screens has a read time
approximately 2 minutes per plate so if
I've applied read buffer to my plates
plate one goes right in the wait time is
negligible plate 30 at the end of that
Dec has been waiting an additional 60
minutes in the concept of a screening
environment those two plates are not
directly comparable was one incubated
for one hour the other one incubated for
two setting things up in a scheduled
environment and you'll see some
graphical representations here on the
right side of the slide
staggered overtime so that each step has
a
defined time limit and that's part of
the assay set up your scheduler through
a variety of methods is going to you are
going to tell it or it is going to
determine exactly how long each step
within your protocol takes and that's
liquid handling pleat movement washing
everything is going to have an execution
time associated with it
that's scheduling software will then put
all of those times together and
interleave all of these processes so
each step
can occur with constraints that you have
around it so if you put into your
protocol that you want your plate to
incubate for one hour plus or minus five
minutes your software is going to
schedule all the other tasks to make
sure that that happens and you'll get a
tell-tale slanting of your process bars
and anyone that's ever worked in the
scheduling environment knows exactly
what I mean by this
in that way you can directly compare
play one with plate 30 and since these
are the same methods being performed
over time you can perform you can
compare excuse me
plate one within your campaign to plate
400 in your campaign that was screened
four months later because they are
directly comparable under the same
methods with equal time treatment across
a large facet of time
what testing validation is something
that definitely needs to be done when
implementing any kind of an assay
transfer on to an automated platform and
what this means is you're just looking
to make sure that all of your transfers
are being done in the same fashion and
this also goes hand in hand with QC
validation of any liquid handled or that
you have and there are several services
and technologies out there that can in
assist with that but as an example here
I did a wet test validation of this MSD
platform and I ran a mock screen with
ten plates to assess reproducibility the
first and second column were background
samples the rest of the plate was a
single concentration of reference
antibody we also did this for the span
aid which was going to be dispensing our
reference antibody control curves on
each of the screening plates and when we
did this we noticed that the first and
second replicate of the reference
antibody the curves came in noticeably
lower than the rest of the replicates
and the reason for that was in after
priming the span eight we found that the
weight that occurred
from the initiation of the protocol to
the first application of the control
antibody another priming step would have
been helpful
so simply instituting a pre-wet step
before
Dispensa the police completely resolved
that drift and all of those curves are
right on top of each other but that's
you know it's small things like this as
I said small changes can have big
effects and it's small things like this
that need to be looked at
in conclusion sa is routine or basic
doesn't mean that it wouldn't benefit
from automating the entire or even just
a portion of that a saying consistency
within single experiments and over
extended periods of time is one of the
greatest benefits for instituting
automation of different asset types as I
said equal time treatment can allow you
to directly and safely compare samples
across a wide range of time wet testing
validation of an assay is essential and
critical when looking at how to
implement any type of automation or
workstation approach I always advise
people to keep an eye to the future and
make sure that whatever that they
implement is scalable to future needs
and also comes in line with your
budgetary restrictions
I would like to thank lab roots and I
would also like to thank Beckman Coulter
for bringing me in to be a part of this
educational webinar series we have the
necessary disclosures and copyrights
that the lawyers have insisted and I am
free to take any questions
so up thank you for your presentation a
quick reminder to our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the drop down box located on the far
left of your presentation window labeled
ask a question and click on the send
button Phillip will answer as many
questions as time permits okay Phillip
our first question how do you minimize
edge effect in your automated Eliza well
there's several ways that you can go
about minimizing edge effects the
easiest way to look at that is making
sure that your plates are lidded during
their incubation times I would keep
incubation times themselves as short as
possible while ensuring maximum
performance within your assay other
things that generally escape notice are
your lab environment in general
high degree of air-conditioning can
cause very dry air which can increase
evaporation looking at the assay volume
versus the plate type that you're
working with for example if you're using
a 96-well plate and doing a 50 micro
litre eliza a small degree of
evaporation is going to have a much
larger effect and say if you were doing
100 micro liter eliza or doing it within
three four well plate a much smaller
available surface area for that
evaporation to take place the another
way of looking at it is incubating your
plates with any humidified environment
to keep that evaporation to a minimum
a lot of it depends on the resources
that you have available in the in
general environment that you're working
in
and of our next question is two parts
now based on your experience how easy
was it to program an Eliza on the
biomech and what advice recommendations
you have for an automation novice in my
personal experience is actually quite
easy to program an Eliza protocol
onto a biomech assuming that you're
working with a biomech as a standalone
liquid handler it's basically just a
series of single reagent transfer steps
um and those can be done basically the
same protocol with just a different
source reagent and that's probably one
of the easiest methods to set up within
the biomech software that gets obviously
a little bit more complicated if you
start integrating components on back of
a within a biomech or a biomech or any
other liquid handler is part of an
integrated system
setting up liquid handling protocols
around some of these assays the best
advice I can give for especially for
novice users is don't overthink it if
thing you need to do is add a reagent to
a plate as a it's a simple one single
reagent transfer
making a method overly complex is not
going to benefit you in the long run
that obviously changes once you get into
scheduled environments the level of
complexity increases when you're talking
about integrated devices in the
scheduled environment
we'll say within Sammie as an example of
a scheduled environment setting up an
Eliza protocol is also quite simple the
the most part comes when optimizing that
method for an optimal timing it which is
a part of what I touched on towards the
end of the presentation there
Thank You Philip and a reminder to our
audience um if you'd like to submit any
questions but there is a drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and just type in your question
and click send
okay our next question Philip what's
next do you take to minimize sample to
sample contamination during automation
well there's multiple ways that you can
look at this and it also depends on what
types of samples that you're referring
to some people in will say an effort to
reduce consumables costs Institute tip
wash and most liquid handling platforms
biomech included usually come with the
available option of a tip wash station I
would recommend
a very hard evaluation very stringent
evaluation of your tip wash protocol
also I'm using new tips for every sample
an easy way to avoid cross contamination
using barrier tips is another way if
you're working in more of a molecular
biology standpoint or a phage standpoint
barrier tips would be a necessity I work
a lot with cell culture supernatants and
hybridoma cultures so we have hepa
enclosures around several or apart
liquid handlers to reduce broad
contamination overall like I said
there's it depends a lot on the types of
samples that you're working with in the
types of contamination or cross
contamination that you're worried about
but there's usually multiple ways to
approach those problems
Thank You Philip here's another question
how do you go about troubleshooting and
automated fa
oh very good question this is a primary
reason why benchtop to automation
transfer is so vital
it's all up your ass a method at the
bench manually and you know that your
assay is performing as expected moving
that over to a liquid handling platform
or an integrated platform you start to
see discrepancies or drift it's not the
chemistry or the biology of the assay
that's your problem
way that
think to go about something like that is
and it does take a bit of a familiarity
with the components that you're working
with looking at your point and
identifying the possible causes and then
changing one variable at a time across
your process to identify what part of
that automation process is your culprit
so to speak it does have to be a very
methodical approach and that is a big
reason why I never recommend developing
a G's on automation platforms I would
highly recommend developing them
manually at the bench and then
transferring to an automated platform it
takes a whole set of variables off the
table if you do start to see problems
Philip and it looks like we have time
for one more question but I do want to
remind our audience I've any questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
type of registration okay Philip our
last question how do you access and
visualize data from your automated
assets well there's a couple of things
that come into consideration with that
personally the softwares that we use
here at bi in in my lab here are
primarily graphpad prism and Spotfire
for doing data visualizations accessing
them is where you can run into some
problems sometimes network connectivity
is a big issue and it tends to be a
little easier in academia versus
corporate environments for example our
two automated platforms that we have in
my lab now one that was integrated by
PerkinElmer and one that was integrated
by a Beckman Coulter
neither of them are actually compatible
with our corporate firewall so those
platforms actually are not on our
network so we have to physically
transfer those files through a gateway
computer those restrictions tend to be
tend to vary I guess we'll say from
company to company and academic
institution academic institution but the
as far as the actual data processing and
data visualization the ones that we use
our prism in Spotfire and I'm sure that
there's going to be a preference with
that with most users
thank you again Philip Corman and thank
you to our sponsor Beckman Coulter
Lifesciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
webcasts can't be viewed on tube and
through August 2019 labyrinths will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye